ماسك يفاجئ مستخدمي ابل برسوم اعلى من اجل
التوثيق
وا ملايين يجربون تطبيق للالعاب السحريه
ومتخصصون يتحدثون عن مؤامره ويحضرون من
انتهاك الخصوصيه
وكل ما تحتاج معرفته عن متلازمته الشخص
المتيبس الذي اعلنت سيلين ديون اصابتها به
اهلا بكم
مجموعه من التطورات والقرارات من مصر في
تويتر الايام الماضيه متصدره للعناوين
كلام عن حسابات محظوره او الحسابات
المحظوره وكشف المزيد من فضائح الاداره
السابقه وفسادها كمان كلام كثير عن حساب
ترامب وحضره ومن اقل من 24 ساعه في تطور
جديد
ومنتظر فاتر تويتر
بلو وهي الخدمه اللي راح تكون باشتراك
شهري واللي من ضمن المميزاتها توفيق
الحساب مميزات اخرى عديده واللي من لما
ماسك اعلن عنها وهي عامله نوع من انواع
الاشكالات هاي الخدمه مقابل 8 دولارات
شهريا كانت من وقت ما اعلن عنها ماسك
عامله جدله كبير ومشاهير كثير حتى اعلنه
تركل منصه او قالوا انها ما انهم ما راح
يدفعوا حتى لو خسروا توثيق الحساب عموما
اعلان تويتر الجديد قال انه الخدمه خلص
راح تطرح غدا الاثنين ومن ضمن ميزاتها
توفيق بعد ان تتم مراجعه الحساب وتعديل
التغريدات وتحميل الفيديوهات بجوده عاليه
جدا وغيرها واعلنت الشركه كمان انها قريبا
جدا رح تكون حسابات الشركات راح تكون
بالفعل رمز التوثيق لالها باللون الذهبي
والحكومات راح تكون بالرمادي كل هذه
التفاصيل سمعناها من قبل في تسريبات
وتقارير ومكانت مفاجاه الحقيقه لكن
المفاجاه الكبرى كانت بالاشتراك الشهري
تويتر اعلن انه الاشتراك راح يكون ثمانيه
دولارات شهريا واللي بشترك عن طريق الويب
هذا طبعا عن طريق الويب اما اللي راح
يشترك عن طريق اي او اس يعني عن طريق
اجهزه ايفون او ايفون هذا راح يدفع 13$ في
الشهر يعني من الاخر ماسك بيقول لمستخدمين
ابل راح تدفع اكثر
ليه بنقول انه الموضوع مفاجاه لانه اولا
ما سمعنا ولا حتى تسريبات عن الموضوع من
قبل هيك وثانيا لانه ماسك المفروض خلاص
صلح الامور ما اقل لو متذكريه من اسبوعين
تقريبا ماسك فجه في سلسله تغريدات شن حرب
طاحنه على ابل وحكى عن نيه الشركه حجم
تويتر من متجررها وعمل استفتاء للناس عن
انفلو زبائنها وعمل كمان منشن لرئيس قابل
حتى وقال انه الشركه وقفت اعلاناتها على
تويتر وتكلم كمان وهجمهم وقال انهم
بيفردوا ما سماه ضريبه سريه 30% على كل
شيء على مجرهم ومش بس هيك بس حتى وصلت في
انه يؤكد انه مستعد يصنع هاتف ينافس في
ايفون يعمل هيك لكن بعدها بكم يوم على طول
ماسك نشر فيديو من داخل مقر شركه ابل وقال
انه التقى
نصا انه كان في محادثات جيده بيني وبين
بنتكم وانهم حلوا سوء تفاهم اللي صاير
واطل اكدت انها ابدا ما فكرت بحضره تطبيق
من متجررها وناس افترضت انه خلص الامور
تمام وتصلحت لكن مع اعلان اليوم رجعت
الكثير من الاسئله هل معنى الرسوم لزياده
لمستخدمي ابولو الدنيا بين ماسك وابل لسه
متوتره والحرب نزلت قائمه راح نسال هذا
السؤال لضيفنا في رياض الخبير التقنيه عبد
العزيز الحمادي اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ عبد
العزيز معنا في تفاعلكم نطرح حلقه نفس
السؤال هل معنى ذلك بانه الحرب ما زالت
قائمه وما تصلح اي شيء ما بينهم ماسكو تيم
كوك لما تقابلوا
طبعا اتخيل انه اليوم لمسك يعني وقت زياره
لشركه ابل حاول بطريقه او باخرى فعليا
استثناء 30 بالمئه الخاصه بي يعني
اشتراكات تويتر بلو اللي يدفع المستخدمين
ولكن من طبيعه الحال اقل تعتبر الاشتراكات
حق حصري واساسي لها لن تتنازل عنه لانه ما
تنازلت قبل مع تطبيقات شهيره مثل النت
فلكس نت فليكس واجهت نفس التحدي مع شركه
ابل عده سنوات 30% اللي كان ياخذها شركه
ابل من مشتركين نتفليكس اللي يشتركون عن
طريق الايفون همم واللي جعل شركه نت فلكس
انها تلقي الاشتراك والدفع عن طريق
التطبيق وتاهت الدفع فقط عن طريق المنصه
الالكترونيه عن طريق الويب بنفس
القيمه لم تتغير سياسه كتاب النهائيه فنفس
القضيه حصلت مع شركه تويتر شركه ابل لم
تتنازل ولا اتوقع تتنازل عن 30% نعتبر
حصري ولكن في نهايه المطار شركه تافه ده
من تويتر بانها تمتلك او يعني على مجرها
الكتروني تطبيقي يعتبر من افضل التطبيقات
الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي على مستوى
العالم وفي نهايه المطاف ايضا الى مصر لن
يستطيع في طريقه او باخرى انه يعني يترك
شركه همم ابل او ان يخسرها خاصه انه عدد
كبير جدا من المستخدمين في امريكا في
العالم العربي وفي غيرها من الدول يقوم
باستخدام تويوتا
همم يعني همم يطلب 13 دولار شهريا من
مستخدم وبتقول انه عمل ما راح تتنازل انا
ما اتنازلت قبل هيك عن النسبه نسبه
الارباح بالنسبه لها طب همم مين اللي راح
يعاني مستخدمي ابل في هذه الحاله راح
يضيعوا هل نقدر نقول انه راح يضيعوا ما
بين طمع تويتر او الى ماسك
طبعا اليوم ماسكي يدير شركه تويتر كشركه
خاصه فيه يريد تحقيق عوائد ماليه تغطي
الخسائر الكبيره اللي يعني صرفها اثناء
شرائه لشركه تويتر فوق طريقه اخرى لا يريد
التنازل عن الثمانيه دولار اللي بناء عليه
وقام بعمليه عمليات حسابيه كثيره من انه
هي من ستفقده من الخسائر الكبيره في يوم
همم وصلت الى ال ال شركه ابل وانه 30%
ياخذون فانت تتكلم تقريبا عن قرابه
الثلاثه الجروح حتى اخذها شركه ابل من
ثمانيه دولار خذ بالك بزياده هذه الزياده
لكن ماسك ذكي قام بايتاحه انه انت في
النهايه لكن الخيار كمستخدم تريد اشتراك
عن طريقه تطبيق ادفع هذا المبلغ
11$ ولكن اذا اردت الدفع 8$ ان كانك
الخروج فقط من التطبيق وفتحه عن طريق
المتصفح بنفس الطريقه ستقوم فقط بدفع
ثمانيه دولار فتخيل انه اغلب لمين سيادتكم
عبد العزيز ما بتعتقد بانه هذا راح يؤثر
على شعبيه تويتر لانه لما انحكي عن 8
دولارات قامت الدنيا وما قعدته في ناس
ومشاهير كثير قالوا انهم راح يغلقوا
حساباتهم ما بدهم يستعملوه تويتر اصلا همم
ما بتعتقد بانه 13 دولار بغض النظر حتى لو
في طريقه
لالتفاف عليها ما راح تعمل مشكله عند
المستخدمين
يعني تحدي لبعض المستقيم والاستثمار في
تويتر ولكن على ال- ال- يعني التجارب
السابقه اللي حصلت في نتفليكس وغيره من
الشبكات اللي اجبرت على دفع مبالغاليه
ورفعت الاسعار في البدايه كان في نزول لكن
في النهايه لا تسال الاعداد تزيد همم الى
ماسكه اعلى من قبل الفتره انه عدد
المستخدمين الجدد الذي يسجلوا في تويتر 2
مليون مستخدم جديد يوميا يعني احنا نتكلم
تقريبا في السنه الواحده بس اذا استمر على
نفس الاعداد 700 مليون مستخدم جديد يعني
خلال سنه اذا استمرت على نفس الاعداد سيصل
عدد المستخدمين الى قرابه مليار مستخدم
همم في شبكه تويتر لذلك الاعداد لا تزال
في زياده على حسب الارقام اللي جالسين
يشوفها فلا يتخيل انه هذا سيسبب عائل يعني
عائق لانه الدفع هذا ليس لمزايا اساسيه في
تويتر انما مزايا اضافيه همم
الرفع الفيديوهات عاليه الدقه او ربما
علامه توثيق معينه اصبح هذه العلامه ليست
بصراحه ذات قيمه مستقبلا خاصه الى الواحد
اصبح يشتريها طيب عبد العزيز الحمادي
الخبير التقنيه لو سمحت ابقى معنا في
لدينا موضوع تقني اخر رح نتحدث فيه بعد
قليل
في ابلكيشن جديد
من غير سابق انذار شفنا الناس من حول
العالم وفجاه مغرقين الانستغرام بالصور
اللي بينتج هذا التطبيق هو هذا التطبيق
للصور والتزبيطها والتعديل عليها لكن
المميز اللي في اللي انتشرت بشكل كبير هي
ببساطه انه المشترك بيدفع اربع دولارات
تقريبا وبصور حاله 10 او 20 صوره سيلفي
بزوايا مختلفه والابليكيشن بعدين بيعمل
مجموعه كبيره من الصور المعروفه الان باسم
افاتار يعني ببساطه صور كرتونيه لشخصيته
خلال 20 ل 40 دقيقه بالكثير الابراج
السحريه بتكون جاهزه التطبيق بيستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي وعمل او عمل النجاح
وانتشار مش طبيعي حول العالم
لتطبيق من اول شهر يعني من 10 ايام فقط
واكثر من ثمانيه مليون دولار الدفع على
هذا التطبيق طبعا هذا انتشار مش طبيعي وعم
عملوا التطبيق مثل ما قلنا او ذكرنا او هو
هذا التطبيق اذا بتذكره مشاهدينا بتذكرنا
بتطبيق اسمه فيس اب انتشر بشكل كبير من
حوالي ثلاث سنين وهو برده تطبيق لتعديل
الصور وقتها كانت الناس بتحط صورها
والتطبيق بيتخيل كيف راح يكون شكلهم في
مراحل الشيخوخه عموما مثل ما صار مع فيس
ايضا شفنا شكله راح يصير مع لانسر فورا
ظهرت سيل من التحضيرات المتعلقه بالخصوصيه
واللي بتقول انه بمجرد تحميل التطبيق
والموافقه على شروطه المستخدم بيعطي
الموافقه انه يستخدم صوره ويبيعها كمان
لشركات ثانيه في ناس حتى بتحضر انه او
تحذيراتها بتروح ابعد من هيك وبتقول انه
اصلا للتطبيقات هاي ما هي الا مصيده
لايقاع الناس في الشباك
ولتجميع بياناتهم احنا على كل حال راح
اعود لضيفنا عبد العزيز الحمادي لنحكي عن
هذا الموضوع عبد العزيز هل التحضيرات فيما
يتعلق بلنساي اي اي في مكانها ام انه يعني
تحضيرات ليست بجديده وبنقدرش نقول انها
خاصه بهذا التطبيق يعني دون عن تطبيقات
اخرى كل من نستعملها
ومعلوماتنا صارت وين مكان اصلا
طبعا اليوم مثلا تطبيق صراحه ااا بالعكس
التحذير جدا هام منها ومن امثالها من
التطبيقات وذكرتي راويه ما حصل فعليا مع
تطبيق فيس ابل المرحله الفعليه قام
باستخدام عدد هائل من صور ملايين
المستخدمين حول حول العالم لو عدنا الى
تطبيق الانذائي
مفهوم الذكاء الاصطناعي هو لا يصبح دقيق
الذكاء الاصطناعي الا بحجم البيانات الذي
التي يقوم بتجميعها فاذا كان عنده عدد
هائل من الصور ملايين وربما مليارات من
الصور في النهايه سيصبح هذا التطبيق ادق
واكثر قدره على التخيل والاستفاده عفوا
افاده المستخدمين بطبيعه الحال انا همم
يعني لو حلف تطبيق همم
على المصحف على اي همم كتاب اخر همم
سيستخدمه الصور ولن يصدقه في هذا الامر
لذلك انه يحذر يعني لو كتبوا بالبطن
العريض لانه لن هو باستخدام هذه الصوره
وانها سيتم حذفها لن يسلقوا في هذا الامر
لانه هذه الصور تعتبر قيمه عاليه بشكل
كبير جدا لهم ولن يستطيعوا الاستمرار الا
اذا استحوذوا على هذه السوره
يعني او بتحذر من انه ممكن يستخدم صورنا
ويبيعوها لشركات ثانيه طب في تطبيقات كثير
احنا بنستعملها منها تويتر انستغرام كثير
من تطبيقات التواصل الاجتماعي ما هي
بتستخدم صورنا طب احنا شو بعرفنا انهن ما
عم يبيعوها او يستخدموها باي شكل احنا ما
بنرضى عنه
الرفع الصور الشخصيه او اي صور على اي
خدمه الكترونيه سيتم استخدامها الفرق ماذا
الفرق انك لو رفعتيه على تويتر انت عارفه
انه هو اصبح منشور على تويتر لو رفعتيه
على السناب شات لو عرفتي رفعتيه على غيره
لكن بعض التطبيقات الشخصيه يقوم
باستخدامها ويتوقع انه هذه الصور ستبقى
داخل التطبيقه تمشي تحلف لذلك يقوم
بمشاركه اشياء خاصه اشياء يتوقع انه ما
يتم نشرها وما يتم فعليا الاستفاده منها
لكن
نحن نبين لا سيتم الاستفاده من ذلك الخطر
في هذه التطبيقات اعلى بشكل كبير مقارنه
بتطبيقات اخرى مثل تويتر فلذلك مثل تطبيق
لنزع هاي هاي سيقوم بجمع ملايين الصور
واستثمار وتعالى
نقطه واحده يعني عملنا بنقول للناس اللي
بده يستخدم تطبيق لنسى ايه اي اي يتاكد
انه الصور اللي بيبعثها بيرسلها لهذا
التطبيق هو ما عنده مانع انها تنتشر اصلا
ولكن هل بنتحدث عن انه هذا التطبيق عنده
اكسس على صورنا اللي احنا ما بدنا ننشرها
كمان
ممكن استخدمها ولا بس اللي بنبعث له
بنرسلها او نرسلها للتطبيق لحتى يعدل
عليها لا فقط الصور التي يقوم الشخص
برفعها اذا رفعت اذا رفع المستخدم صوره هي
الصوره اللي بيتم يعني نشرها واستخدامها
ربما يتم حتى اختراق التطبيق مستقبلا وجلب
مثل هذه الصور لكن الصور اللي في جهازك
الخاص فيك لن يتم الوصول لها لانه اجهزه
الهواتف الذكيه فيها من الحمايه يعني ما
يسمح بالشخص انه يعني مشاركه صور معينه هي
من من يتم رافعها على هذا التطبيق شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد العزيز الحمادي الخبير
التقني كان معنا من الرياض
فجاه النجم الكنديه العالميه سيلين ديون
العالم كله من ايام باعلان محزن ومؤثر
نشرته عبر حساب على الانستغرام وفي تعلن
عن اصابتها بمرض عصبي نادر اسمه متلازمه
الشخص المتيبس
انها تعلق جولتها في ربيعه 2023 وتاجلها ل
2024 بشكل كامل ثمانيه من حفلاتها في
الصيف 2013 من وقت هذا الاعلان المؤلم
واسم الفنانه في العناوينز ونهاله تتمنيات
بالشفاء عليها من مختلف مشاهير العالم
ومحبيها والجمهور العام كمان ومع هذا
تداول الخبر زاد البحث بشكل كبير عن
متلازمه الشخص المتلبس وملايين من حول
العالم صاروا بيتزا النادر
من التفاصيل عنهم في تفاعل
استعان الدكتوره منى عبد الفتاح ندى
استاذه امراض المخ والاعصاب لا تشرح لنا
اكثر عن هذا المرض خلينا نتفق نتابعه ما
هو
الحقيقه ده مرض نادر جدا حدوثه بيحصل واحد
في المليون يصيب النساء اكثر ليس له سبب
معروف لغايه دلوقت شايفين سببه بيحصل
مشكله في المناعه ان المناعه تعلى فتبتدي
تصيب او تؤثر على ماده اسمها جلوتاميك
اسيد ديكربوكسريس الماده دي دورها انها
توصل للجهاز العصبي الاشارات العصبيه
فتبتدي العضله تتحرك لما بيحصل خلل في
المناعه يبتدي يحصل مشكله في المخ وفي
النخاع الشوكي فتبتدي تدي اعراض كثيره
للمريض
ايه هي اعراض المرض ده بيحصل تيبس شديد في
العضلات وتبتدي العضلات الجذعيه اللي لها
علاقه بالصدر والبطن لاول عضلات تتاثر
وبعد كده بالسين طويله يبتدي يتاثر الساق
والذراع يحصل ايه للمريض يبقى فيه صعوبه
في الحركه شديده حساسيه شديده جدا للصوت
او لللمس تختفي الاعراض تماما اثناء النوم
طيب هل له خطوره على المريض او هو مرض
قاتل هو خطورته انه بيعمل اعاقه مع تقدم
المرض يبتدي يحصل صعوبه في الحركه قد تؤدي
الى احتياج المريض لمساعده من الاخرين
وتحتاج الى اعانه طول الوقت لكنه ليس مرض
قاتل
هل هيستمر وليس له علاج علاج ينقسم
الحقيقه لادويه لعلاقه بالمناعه فبتدي تدي
دواء زي الاي في اي جي او انيونوجلوبيليس
ديت بتعمل اعاده لتنظيم المناعه بتاعت
الجسم او بنعمل فصل في لازمه وبندي دواء
اسمه بيتكسباب كل دي ادويه بتشتغل على
المناعه جزء ثاني من العلاج اللي احنا
بندي ادويه بواسط للعضلات فالتيبس الشديد
المريضه بتحس به يبتدي يتحسن الجزء الثالث
من العلاج اللي احنا بنعمل علاج طبيعي ما
فيش حاجه كافيه شافيه تماما من المرض هو
بيفضل يستمر الى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد علاج
تام وشافي تماما ولكنه كلها محاولات
لتعديل المناعه اللي حصل فيها خلل فتبتدي
التيابس يكون اقل ضرر للمريض
[موسيقى]
انتقل موضوع اخر بعد ايام من اعلان المدعي
العام الايراني حل ما يعرف بشرطه الاخلاق
ودوريات الاداب الي بتكون فيها واللي كانت
واحده منها القتل القبض على ساميني قبل ما
اقتلها في مركز الشرطه وبعد الجدل اللي
صار اصلا حول فعليا حلها من عدمه او جدوى
وجديه الخطبه الخطوه لو صحيحه في فيديو
منتشر على المنصات بشكل كبير وفي تقوم
نساء ايرانيات بالتصدي لنساء شرطه الاخلاق
وبتطردهم من حافله في طاهره خلينا نشوف
نعم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا انتشار المقطع هذا بيجي بعد
ايام بس من تسميه مجله تايم الامريكيين
يعني نساء ايران ابطال العالم لا دورهم او
الرائد طبعا في الاحتجاجات في البلاد هذا
غير تسميه المجله ايرانيه ضمن اكثر مئه
امراه ملهمه ومؤثره في العالم ومنهم عدد
من الناشطات والمتظاهرات الايرانيات
ولك وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم من تفاعلكم
مشاهدينا موعدنا فيكم بيتجدد غدا شكرا لكم
والى اللقاء